[Musique]
samoussas zachar bonbons piments et
rougail la morue étaient au menu ce week
end à l'antenne départementale
l'occasion pour l'équipe de la
collectivité de partager un sourire et
un repas avec les réunionnais
bénéficiaires du dispositif
d'accompagnement des malades
c'est un moment convivial que l'on passe
aujourd'hui avec les accompagnants de
malades et les malades réunionnais notre
but aujourd'hui c'est est de favoriser
l'entr'aide l'écoutent avec les
accompagnants de malades et leur montrer
que le département est présent et ne les
oublie pas dans les moments difficiles
qu'ils ont à vivre pendant la durée de
leur séjour médical un engagement
volontariste du département pour aider
ces personnes vulnérables dans ce moment
difficile de la vie de leurs proches ici
aujourd'hui c'est une première parce que
nous l'a regroupé 20 30 40
accompagnant qu'elle a besoin d'être
ensemble de comprendre combien espace
pour trois autres entre réunionnais ne
manger ni manger créole mais de pouvoir
diazote va nous aider pas tout seul le
dispositif départemental s'adapte aux
situations même les plus urgentes et
vient en complément de la contribution
de la sécurité sociale la mission
première de l'année chercher les gens à
l'aéroport et conduire dans leur métier
pâques accueille qui est constitué d'un
plan de de paris des tickets de train
pour qu'ils débutent leur séjour ici
ensuite y'a un téléphone un téléphone
qu'il n'ait pas ensuite on est conduit
au dans un hébergement s'appelle de
rousies rouge ça peut être la croisée à
cette écurie et ses bunkers et après
pendant tout le séjour on a un suivi
personnalisé en fonction de ce que la
demande la personne 3la nous c'est de
faire l'écoutent et nos soutiens ces
personnes c'est dire qu'on va lui rendre
visite dans les centres d'hébergement
on voit leurs besoins on les écoute est
également numéro vert qui qui fonctionne
24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 sur
les caniveaux appelé pain pour discuter
pour parler de leur situation pour
évacuer en fait est souvent les gens
appellent entre 20 auteurs viennent deux
hommes parce que c'est l'un des leurs
ils vont sans doute hôpital donc ils ont
besoin d'en parler et c'est ça le but du
numéro vert en fait toutes ces personnes
vont reprendre leur travail de soutien
auprès de leurs enfants ou de leurs
proches
un moment de répit qui permet de voir
l'avenir avec un peu plus d'énergie
[Musique]